begin
you know i hear that a lot like where do
i start i would say there is a huge
power in beginning and there's huge
power in starting it's almost like the
universe begins to support you when you
take that first step yes i would say
believe in you when no one else believes
in you until the whole world believes in
you
i think the reason why we even have the
question
of where do i begin is from fear
we're paralyzed
so it's start to believe in yourself and
start to read books and realize all the
great heroes
were anonymous for 25 or 30 years before
the world celebrated them
um i would also say
genius is less about genetics and more
about your habits so you know start with
the philosophy
of beginning and starting start to
believe in yourself understand that
you're going to be laughed at you're
going to be misunderstood and every
great hero is misunderstood at the
beginning but then install the right
habits and this is where the this is
where the methodology does follow the
philosophy
once you get the philosophy which is
just the truth what do you want your
life to stand for
what's most important to you what are
your big five for the rest of your life
what are the key values and beliefs you
want to live by once you get the
philosophy calibrated
and you don't follow the world's
philosophy you have the bravery and
wisdom to trust what feels right to you
then start installing the habits that
science have proven to work and for me
it's been the 5 a.m club is very
powerful the five great hours rule the
second wind workout which is basically
if you believe exercise is valuable why
would you only do it once a day
the
micro bravery a great pl pre-sleep
workout the weekly design system etc
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
robin sharma and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy
rule number two practice being excellent
it's easier to behave yourself into a
new way of thinking than think yourself
into a new way of acting
so act first
and then you'll start to think and
believe it as opposed to think and
believe and then start acting practice
being spectacular long enough that
unspectacular unspectacularity
has no ability to enter your orbit
right i mean how do you how does how do
the great athletes become great you know
this you're an opera right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right the same nonsense it's
just practicing non-stop and the the
behavior researchers call it
automaticity
right you practice people well how do i
get
discipline well discipline is a muscle
you are under someone's undisciplined
and then you get out of the bed and you
get up early or you make your bed or you
do 25 push-ups or whatever
and you do it and you do it and you do
it through the power of neuroplasticity
the malleability of the human brain it's
almost like a metaphors for anyone who
wants to make a change who says i can't
do it well your can't do it is the
reason why you're not doing it
because the can't do it
is your weaker self versus your heroic
self
so
it's almost like a metaphor you wake up
in the morning you know and you want to
do something
let's say it's to be a better more
focused better performer because an
addiction and distraction is the depth
of your creative production
so it's almost like a wide open mountain
meadow
and the first time you practice turning
off your phone and practicing what i
call in the everyday hero manifesto the
five great hours rule forget working
more than five great hours a day
five sweaty intense hours so say you
want to practice that it's almost like
you're walking in a mountain meadow
and it's a pure mountain meadow you do
it after a few weeks now the meadow
becomes a trail because you've practiced
it eventually the trail
becomes a road and you keep on
practicing it and eventually the road
becomes a highway and if you keep on
practicing it the highway becomes a
super highway and then if you look at
the neurobiology you've got this circuit
and around it is my starts to form a
fatty tissue called myelin and some
people believe some neuroscientists
believe that myelin is the secret of
genius that's why wayne gretzky could
send the puck to where it was going
versus where it was that's why steve
jobs could see around corners and he was
this favorite word i love prescient he
could see where everything was going
before anyone else could
it's not because these people are cut
from a different cloth it's because they
run different protocols think different
thoughts and they do different things
and what i'd say to wrap that up is
to have the results only five percent of
the population has we've got to be
willing
to be brave enough and faithful enough
to do what only
what 95 of the population are unwilling
to do
rule number three improve yourself every
day
such power
in personal improvement i saw a comment
section of an online newspaper and
someone was mocking
the idea of self-improvement but
michelangelo's david in florence
beethoven's moonlight sonata
jonas salks vaccine
the ceiling of the sistine chapel
da vinci's mona lisa the taj mahal
those were all examples of
self-improvement
our civilization has got to where it's
at right now through the progress of
people who improve themselves by
reaching deep within themselves
and saying i am more than i currently am
and i have a vision
and i will materialize it when it's easy
when it's hard when it's dark when
there's sunshine when i'm doubtful when
i'm confident
so the second word representing the
second piece of advice i'd give if i was
dying let's say would be grow use each
day as a platform to build your
knowledge base so you can deliver more
value use each day to grow in your
self-awareness use each day to grow your
muscles and your physicality use each
day to read and pray and meditate and
journal
so you grow into your and glorify your
greatness number four keep your promises
being meticulous if not impeccable
around promise keeping is a
great
way to increase your self-discipline and
your willpower and your character and
your spirituality
if you say to someone you will call them
next week to take them for lunch
do it you say to someone you're reading
an amazing new book you've heard about
it it's called the everyday hero
manifesto or any book of course
and you say you'll send it to them
because you love it so much
do it
and as you become meticulous and
outright impeccable with keeping your
promises
you get to a place where you simply
cannot not
follow through in your promises i've
built such credibility in other people's
eyes but it really gives you this iron
will
even if you say you're gonna do a
workout so your self promises follow
through on those the more you follow
through on self promises the stronger
your willpower gets remember it's like a
muscle
the more you use it the more you
exercise it the stronger it will become
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five listen to your
heart i believe there are actually three
other interior empires that complete
a personal heroism equation mindset is
it important absolutely because that's
your psychology your daily behavior
reflects your deepest beliefs unless you
upgrade your psychology
then your behavior will always be
limited and no question positive
thinking is important but i there's a
chapter in the book called the the big
lie of positive thinking yes get into
that but yeah so your mindset's
important having said that there are
three other interior empires the second
is your heart set
now this a lot of people i know so many
entrepreneurs and industry titans and
professional sports superstars follow
your work this could sound like
a little flaky and weak actually it's
incredibly powerful to purify your heart
set because your mindset is your
psychology your heart set is your
emotionality yeah we are as human beings
we have emotions
it was a wide open heart that allowed
beethoven to do the moonlight sonata it
was a wide open heart that allowed
shakespeare to do his work or hedy
lamarr to invent if you look at the most
successful even industry titans these
people are being driven by a compelling
cause steve jobs yes did what he did not
because he cared about money steve jobs
did what he did because he was an artist
who wanted to bring great beauty to the
world i heard an interview yesterday on
tributes after his death
from people who knew him and they said
he would he was yes he would get angry
because he was so invested in his mighty
mission
in making the world a better place he
was almost evangelical he was almost
evangelical there was there was one
thing i found this so fascinating he
called one of his designers two in the
morning when they were working on the
iphone designer wakes up yes steve
he says um steve jobs says well you know
in the back of the iphone there's three
screws
designer says but that's inside no one's
ever gonna see those don't worry steve
steve jobs says yes but we know those
three screws are there
and two screws are going to be much
better
fix it
so so heart set
is
our up our higher level emotions like
gratitude awe and wonder
and yet here is the key point our heart
set also is all the suppressed emotions
that we pick up as we go through life
carl jung called it the shadow side
sigmund freud said all of the suppressed
emotions that we do not feel like guilt
anger shame disappointment frustration
that we pick up as we go through life if
those are not dealt with
they come back in ugly ways
and so and there's suppressants to your
genius well that's that is the absolute
key because if our society doesn't
welcome us to work through those
so what it creates is in the book i call
it a field of hurt
and so you can do go to all the
productivity courses you can read all
the business books you can learn exactly
what to do about mindset
but you're never going to get to world
class here or greatness because there
will always be a block between who you
are and who you truly are because of all
of those suppressed emotions once you
learn how to release them
you get intimate with your inner heroism
you your creativity source your
productivity source you actually open
your heart to love great products are
made of love great teams are built of
love great movements are launched from
love then there's so there's mindset
there's heart set there's health set and
then there's soul set soul set is your
spirituality i'm not necessarily talking
about religion
but once you turn down the loud voices
of your ego
we can talk about the tools to do it but
and you start to hear the silent
whispers of your inner hero
you start living the truth
and when you do that consistently you
become the most powerful person in every
room that you're in
and you don't need to worry about
branding
because your character and your energy
and your love
is the messenger for every single thing
you do rule number six own your truth
there are only two reasons why we are
alive and i think if we strip away the
accessories and the trinkets that the
world sells to us as the metrics of
success like how many social media likes
do you have how much money do you have
how much fame
in the book i say ff
jpf is always more valuable than ffa
joy peace and freedom is a million times
more valuable than fame fortune and
applies and ask anyone who has fame
fortune and applies
[Music]
what they would be willing to give
for joy
peace
and freedom
so
we get to live the great thing about
being human is we get to live as we wish
and i'm in no position to judge how
anyone's living personally i believe
when we get to the last hour for our
last day and we strip away all the
things people are so many people are
chasing
i
deeply believe only two things will
matter
number one
who did you become
as compared to our promise
how much of it did we materialize
through the work we're talking about and
number two how many people did we help
yeah i mean
you know to me it's like
and and they're connected because the
more you own your truth and move through
the layers of fear doubt disbelief into
your most creative productive powerful
loving decent noble self the more you
will start to see yourself as an
instrument of service to the world i
think that's our fundamental nature it's
to give rule number seven leave your
comfort zone leave the safe harbor of
the known
because it's the most dangerous place to
be hug your monsters embrace your
dragons you will realize you have been
limiting your life based on a series of
illusions that were taught to you and
programmed into you and that were
brainwashed and heart washed
against your genius
invent
go blue ocean versus stay in the safe
harbor of the known
ask yourself what product service
magic can i bring to the marketplace
that no one else is daring to do don't
copy create
invent
and invent your life
once you are at a place where you know
all the answers to your biggest
questions tear it all down
reinvent yourself move to a new country
start reading new books try a new
business become a new person
invent is what i would say never stop
improving that acronym i've been
teaching nsi never stop improving
maintain that white belt mentality
the thing about a master is she never
thinks she's a master she always
operates like a beginner final the fifth
word i would offer to you with great
love respect and faith in your
brilliance rule number eight choose to
do difficult things it is so powerful to
be in the business of doing hard things
what makes a leader what a what's an
entrepreneur it's someone who literally
understands that you get paid to find
solutions to difficult things
in your life as a human being outside of
business
choose difficult things choose the
longer run choose the harder workout
read the difficult book have the hard
conversation
vote for the challenging project that no
one else in your industry will do
that is a great way
to develop built willpower because as
you
move through the project towards
completion
it draws hidden forces and strengths
that you did not know you had
out to see the light of day and you get
to know how powerful you are rule number
nine stop being busy i would say an
addiction a distraction is the death of
your creative production
when it comes to productivity
in the everyday hair manifesto there is
a revolutionary rule called the five
great hours rule
so you don't need to work for seven
hours a day i do not subscribe to hustle
and grind i don't work for more than a
few hours a day
i take
i work four hours every week i take four
months plus off every single year how i
do it is in the book including the
weekly design system
when i work i i'm away from distraction
there's a difference between real work
and that's right there's a difference
between real work and fake work
let us not confuse busy
with productivity let us not confuse
movement with impact so i think that's
really important
we can get into the menlo park and the
type of total focus structures but you
talked about family yet
and
i believe the greatest gift we can give
another human being is the gift of our
presence
and if you look at the greatest heroes
and the greatest leaders they had an
ability
to be there
and
and the very fact you said it means you
do practice it and i can tell everyone
watching right now you have so much
presence and i'm not talking about
charisma which you have
you're talking about you are here
in a world where a lot of people are
cyber zombies and
you know
just not present so i think you can
change the world and live a world-class
life
or you can play with your phone all day
you can't do both and we could get into
the science of
emotional residue every single time you
check a notification every single time
you like something and number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips
is live a life of service
serve
it's the formula for happiness find a
cause that's larger than yourself and
donate the remainder of your life to it
serve
meet someone on the street try to make
them
leave them better than you found them
serve in your business life be a servant
leader servant hero ask yourself how can
i deliver magic and value to them
serve serve your family if you have
children grow your children develop your
children inspire your children your
significant other help that person
become the person that they're meant to
be serve the world in your own unique
way
that would be my advice
to you if i were dying
so the research as i mentioned at uh
university college of london says it
takes 66 days for any human being to
wire any in a in a habit and we all have
a gift called neuroplasticity so we all
can do it and then the model i i share
in the book is called the habit
installation protocol and basically it's
22 days called installation excuse me
called destruction
to get up early you've got to destroy
your old neural patterns and emotional
signatures of getting up later
that doesn't happen in an instant all
change is hard at first messy in the
middle gorgeous at the end so that first
destruction phase is 22 days there's
nothing wrong society says it's hard so
it's bad i'm suggesting it's hard so
it's good that's what real change is as
you with that awareness you can stay
with it and get into the second phase
which is
installation and that's like a house
renovation which is messy and that's why
change is messy in the middle
your old pathways and ways of being are
falling apart but you know this because
i sense you have a very deep grounding
in that middle part you have to
in some ways let go of who you were it's
called a dark night of the soul
so for 22 days it's it's messy in the
middle because you're letting go of who
you were that's not easy and that's why
habit installation you need to have some
bravery but that's only 22 days stay
with it because then you get to the
third phase which is implementation so
destruction integration implementation
well now we're on the short roads and
the neuroplasticity has kicked in and
the researchers call it automaticity you
will every human being can get to a
place 66 days later approximately where
it actually gets easier to get up at 5am
than to stay in the bed and the point is
it's called automaticity and that's it
you know we all have that ability we
just need to stay with that three-stage
process for 66 days there is a reason
many of the great women and men of the
world the great history makers the great
poets the great philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5 a.m and
that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and i believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is the time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest
there's there's very recent cutting edge
science coming out now when you sleep
your brain actually has a mechanism to
wash itself when you wake up in the
morning your willpower is strongest when
you wake up in the morning you've got a
full well of mental focus and we know
that focus in our world is even more
valuable than intelligence and i could
go on and on on the benefits i mean you
get up at 5 00 a.m you've got the world
to yourself there's no crowds you can
think you can plan you can care for
yourself in a world where so many people
are so depleted and so the fi it the 5
am club really is a game changer and
then it's not just get up at 5 a.m and
you know scratch your stomach or stare
up at the ceiling or look at your phone
or look at especially i believe you can
play with your phone or change the world
you don't get to do both yeah and so uh
it the 5am club method is based on the
20 20 20 formula i'm happy to get into
it but that is tell us what it is that's
the revolutionizer and and it started
from my experience with working with
many billionaires i i've coached many of
the most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day and so
the 20 20 20 formula that the book is
based upon is pretty simple i i go into
great detail in the book but
essentially it's from 5 to 5 20 the
first pocket is move
and i'm a fanatic about neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter you're going to release
norepinephrine which will boost your
focus you'll promote neurogenesis marie
you can actually grow new brain cells
increase your metabolic rate so the way
you beg the way you feel when you first
wake up is not the way you're going to
feel at 5 20. second pocket of the 20 20
20 formula 20 minutes from 5 20 to 5 40
that's on reflection so a lot of us are
busy but what's the point of being busy
if you're doing the wrong things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal
you can visualize you can pray you can
meditate you can simply
contemplate
how you're going to live your day what
you want to stand for during the day for
example and then the final pocket of the
20 20 20 formula is all about grow and
that's where you you just read from a
biography or a business book or a
philosophy book or uh watching marietv
well especially watching tv yeah of
course that's the game changer isn't it
and so that's 20 minutes of growing
because i think we're most alive when we
are growing yes and um i believe the
leader who learns the most wins so
that's in a nutshell the 20 20 20
formula you see most people in the room
no that's not everyone in the room has
been traumatized no one talks about this
oh this is a business event you're
talking about trauma
everyone in this room has experienced
trauma at some level or another
to varying degrees
sometimes it wasn't being invited to
someone's party trauma
right
sometimes it was sexual abuse trauma
and so what happens is this is so
important i can spend the whole day on
this but
the human tendency and the cultural
seduction is don't feel the pain of the
trauma everyone know what i'm talking
about around my out on the jagged edges
don't feel the trauma don't feel the
disappointment you got heartbroken don't
go into it
only seek pleasure
only be happy happy happy be put on the
happy face watch the happy tv shows
seek pleasure
and
what we do is we actually flee from
feeling because of the trauma
and we start to live in our heads and we
numb out our body and we don't feel
but to be human is to feel
to be a great leader is to feel
if you look at the greatest empire
builders economically zuckerberg musk
steve jobs great example
[Music]
he felt deeply
you know he lived in a pretty simple
house
even when he was a multi-billionaire
simple house
he wasn't he was only about a few things
he was about family he was about
you know what he said i love this
because i'm a purist
i built my build my life around just a
few things
he said my favorite things in life
books and sushi
isn't that beautiful
and he was an artist
he was an artist
and so
mindset without heart set so we
experience trauma and then we block it
out repress it and then we lose our
emotional game which is mission critical
to world class you've got to love your
clients you've got to love the beauty of
creating gorgeous products
you've got to want to serve it doesn't
happen in the head
oh you know
service to your clients to the
marketplace
happens in your heart
you
the desire to lead a world-class life
happens
emotionally
and that's how you battle proof yourself
against volatility it's not an
intellectual game it's a visceral game
it's in your dna the thing you talked
about in the book that that really hit
me is this notion of being braver of
finding ways to get braver and i don't
know it was one of those where you're
kind of like trying to guess what the
person is going to say and i was so
struck by that one
how do we practice getting braver what
does it mean to be braver and then how
does that end up being useful for us
what terrifies you most go directly
there
because discomfort is simply
growth in wolf's clothing
well yeah i mean the last chapter
is uh i don't want to give too much away
but it's it's um an experience i live
you know it's it's nelson mandela's
prison cell
have you been to robin island i haven't
but i am beyond obsessed with nelson
mandela so i know the story very well
you know i i i'd encourage you to go
because
standing in that in that cell
feeling
the sensations
will transform you at a soul level as
well as hard set levels so how do we
become more brave well
i went over to
nelson mandela's prison cell and i stood
there and i was shocked he didn't even
have a bed and he was in there for 18
years
then
i went over to the limestone quarry
and i saw where nelson mandela spent 10
years chipping away at stone to break
his spirit because they threw the stones
away
and then i saw the showers where this
elderly statesman would shower while the
young guards would laugh at him
and then in the book i talked about a
true fact where
he was asked on robben island to dig a
grave and he he
got in the grave
thinking he was going to die and the
prison guards urinated on
and my point is simply this when nelson
mandela was released from prison
after 27 years of total incarceration
the he invited the prosecutor who was
seeking the death penalty to dinner
and he invited the prison guard who kept
him in prison for 18 years on robben
island
to his inauguration as president of
south africa and he was asked
why would you do that he said because
if i didn't i'd still be in prison
and my point is to lead and to become a
great hero
or an everyday hero
the doorway is through embracing our
suffering and doing difficult things i
think pleasure
has been promoted too much in our
society like no great
tight enough industry no legendary
cellist
no
great athlete you know the great ones
all understand that suffering is the
price
of greatness so
how do we become braver you you do the
difficult things that you don't feel
like doing but you know have the payoff
there's a reason why
the visionary founder of starbucks
howard schultz
rises before the sun there's a reason
why michelle obama rises very early
there's a reason why tim cook who's
leading apple
gets up before the dawn first of all the
hours between four and six are the time
of least distraction in this age of
dramatic interruption
number two
the hours before the sun rises is the
period where your brain is most
available to your primary creativity so
while you're sleeping your brain
actually washes itself but also it lets
it go the residue of the previous day
while you are resting and while you are
recovering when you wake up your
thinking is fresh your creativity is
most pristine you are most available
to access your gifts and your talents so
those are some of the reasons why i
encourage you to get a brill you might
say robin well i'm not an early riser i
can't put mind over mattress i can't win
the battle of the bed grandma never got
up early dad couldn't get up early i
guess i'm not the kind of person who can
rise before the sun and what i would
suggest to you is simply this
what science confirms in particular the
data of university college london you do
any new habit practice it for 66 days
and you will arrive at the place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not to
66 days
of rising at 5 a.m will get you to a
place where it's easier to get up to 5
a.m then not to get up at 5 00 a.m
you'll reach a place of automaticity
in my book the 5am club i say all change
is hard at first and it's messy in the
middle and it's gorgeous at the end i'll
repeat that again because it's so
important all change is hard at first
messy in the middle and it's gorgeous at
the end in the book there's a chapter on
the habit installation process that
actually explains the three phases every
habit goes through before you wire it
into
the place where it's automatic number
one
destruction
number two
integration and number three
implementation really important to
remember them so you can
get up early you can install habits as a
matter of fact
neuroplasticity which is the phenomenon
uh that speaks to the fact the brain is
like a muscle the more you flex it and
push it the more it's gonna grow you
have that gift it's not just for
federer and serena williams and oprah
winfrey and shakespeare and joe michelle
basquiat and steve jobs and elon musk
you have a brain
that
has the capability to grow and adapt so
what is the 20 20 20 formula that lies
at the core of the 5 a.m club method
well the first 20 minutes move
sweat you'll release bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor which will increase
the neural connections of your brain as
well as repair brain cells damaged by
stress and also promote neurogenesis
which is the formation of new brain
cells i know this is a lot of
information but i want to give you great
content in this video
exercising for 20 minutes first thing in
the morning from 5 to 5 20 the first
part of the 20 20 20 formula releases
dopamine which is the inspirational
neurotransmitter how valuable is that
for your creativity and productivity for
the rest of the day
cortisol the fear hormone is highest
first thing in the morning exercising
will reduce it serotonin is released so
you'll feel happier now it's 5 20 you're
full of energy you've optimized your
cognition
your focus is increasing
it's only 5 20 the rest of the world is
asleep just imagine that advantage you
already have
second pocket for the 20 20 20 formula
is all about reflection we live in a
world where people don't reflect anymore
a lot of people are busy being busy but
what's the point of being busy around
the wrong things so for 20 minutes from
5 20 to 5 40 you reflect you pray or
write in a journal
meditate you can visualize you can
script out a blueprint for a great day
ahead which habit researchers call a
pre-commitment strategy which actually
increases your willpower and your
ability to get your most important
priorities done
okay now it's 5
40 from 5 40 to 6 o'clock this is the
final 20 minute pocket
of the 20 20 20 formula the first pocket
was about move the second is reflect and
the third is grow i've coached
billionaires and ceos and nba superstars
and members of royalty for over 20 years
here's what i've realized when i work
with the best of the best they love to
learn they love to grow they don't see
investing in yourself or investing in
your skills or investing in your growth
a cost they think about the value
received
i call it the 2x 3x mindset to double
your income and your impact triple your
investment in two core areas your
personal mastery and your professional
capability so for 20 minutes what do you
do
you listen to a podcast you review your
journal notes you read a book
you watch a valuable video you just do
something you read an autobiography you
do something to grow your capacities and
materialize more of the potential you
have been born into and now at six
o'clock
you've optimized your mindset you've
purified your heart set you've
calibrated your health set you've
escalated your soul set you feel
fundamentally different in the 5am club
there's another model called the four
habits of history makers and one of the
elements is day stacking the whole idea
is simply this get your mornings right
your days are going to be fundamentally
more energetic creative productive and
high impact and a great week is nothing
more than a series of great days and a
great
month is the same thing and a great
quarter is just a
a series of well-lived weeks
and it just continues and creates this
upward spiral of success just by getting
from five a.m to six
your victory hour to world class every
morning
consistency really is the mother of
mastery and own your morning you're
really going to elevate
your life suffering gets a bad rap in
our world today in society we all want
it quick but if you look at
again nelson mandela mother teresa
mothma gandhi a rosa parks a martin
luther king jr
a marcus aurelius you look at the great
states people the great women who led
who led nations the great men who led
movements you i've been studying samurai
samurai
lately you know i've been studying a lot
of the great warriors i've been reading
a lot about alexander the great you
could say well robin you know in in the
comments section or whatever you could
say robin some of these people were
were bloody you know some of these
warriors and i hear you my larger point
is simply this if you look at the great
warriors or the great
empire builders or the great heroes of
humanity they all had one thing in
common
many of them developed
invincible moral authority to live by
their deepest vision
values and virtues through
the hard winters of deep suffering
a gca a gargantuan competitive advantage
in a world where everyone everyone wants
it easy they want a warm house they want
to
they want a car with heated seats if you
live in a cold place
we want great food we want a life of
ease we want all our devices around us
we want easy friends who don't make us
maybe who don't stretch us we want to if
we even read
we
want easy books we i guess what i'm
suggesting to you is voluntary
discomfort will build you and strengthen
you and the great heroes of history
often didn't do it voluntarily they
suffered they suffered in a prison cell
they suffered for the benefit of their
movement they suffered
long treks through mountains with not a
lot of food when they're on a military
campaign they suffered the
humiliation of being attacked by their
critics and so in this age of ease
we are becoming weak as leaders weak as
humans
weak
as
possibilitarians and i'm just saying to
you sure have your nice things you know
we all want a nice life myself included
and yet make sure you don't fall into
the chasm
or
the
the trap of living a life that is so
easy that you don't develop those
muscles of strength fiery resolve and
moral authority fourth point
persistency
versus the short game
we do live in a world where everything
just happens so fast
that if we have a project or a cause or
a mission
if it doesn't happen
instantly or if it doesn't
manifest or materialize the way we want
it within a month or within a quarter
even within a year
we give up
and we then start chasing the next shiny
toy of opportunity
so
i was in piazza novona in rome a few
weeks ago working on a new book and i
love piazza navona because it's one of
the most beautiful squares on the planet
and when i'm in my creative cycle i go
there
just to refuel and if you walk into
piazza navona what you're going to see
is i think it's called the four rivers
sculpture by bernini
and the point i'm trying to make to you
is as i looked at this
masterpiece of a sculpture
what i realized is the true masters are
not all about impatience they're not all
about
the short game
they understand
that world class is a process and that
genius could take decades and what makes
rare air output is the ability to stick
with a singular vision of your
masterpiece whatever that is a great
company a great family a gorgeous life a
new book a film i don't know
but mastery comes
through deep
focus
patience and persistency and when i
looked at bernini's sculpture
you could see the level of
detail you know and so few people have
it it really is a gargantuan competitive
advantage a gc what i teach in my work
as a gca
a gargantuan competitive advantage
because most people don't have patience
anymore most people
do not have the grit
and the resolve
to stay with a sculpture that's a
metaphor for you their sculpture
for maybe a year on just a little piece
and maybe the next piece of your
sculpture
another year or two years you know it
took
22 years to build the taj mahal
but it became one of the seven wonders
of the world
that's a metaphor for you that i really
want you to think about why do so many
people on the planet right now medicate
themselves they medicate themselves with
too much technology anyone agree with me
show off hands or a round of applause
like they are they are medicating
themselves in front of that white screen
110 times checking the smartphone every
day
that is not checking your technology
you know what that is that is
an addiction
[Music]
and an escape
from what is
and if you said to most people did you
know you're addicted to your smartphone
did you know you're addicted to your
notifications did you know you're
addicted to your television did you know
you're addicted to your excuses did you
know you're addicted to gossip did you
know you're drinking too much alcohol
because you are addicted to it did you
know that this is all a flight from what
is because deep down inside the deepest
unknown part of you knows that you are
in pain over potential
unlived
they would fight you to the death
am i making sense here show of hands
deep down aside i believe most people on
the planet are heartbroken
why because they have betrayed the
visions ambitions values mission in
their heart they have betrayed their
talent
by buying into the mass hypnosis that
the world has sold them and now they're
35 and they're 45 years old
and they're just oh no no this is what
everyone does and they just check check
check and then you know you know what
blaze pascal the french mathematician
said most people
their miser their misery is derived
by their inability to sit quietly in a
room by themselves
you know how many people you know how
many people are frightened of their own
company
and i've shared with you
right no seriously they're frightened of
their own company i've shared with you
the
neurobiology transient hypofrontality
you can't play at edison
you can't play at misty copeland
you can't play it world class
unless you bring yourself away from the
world and do the practice do the
training do the thinking
to set up transient
to set up transient hypo frontality
and that creates the pharmacy of mastery
and it brings you from beta to alpha
and it releases the dopamine and the
serotonin and the psychologists have
told us that state is flow and i guess
what i've been suggesting with transient
hypofrontality you have flow within you
you have genius within you most of us
are so distracted they've they're so
over stimulated
they're so interrupted
that they don't create the silent spaces
where their genius can present
themselves when something doesn't work
out during your day and you get
discouraged you lose your fire
ask yourself this question what's the
opportunity here that's what wtoh stands
for what's the opportunity here what
i've realized is when things don't work
out the victim says oh boohoo poor me
they get stuck in
sadness or anger or regret and some of
them spend the rest of their life in
that state what the leader does is this
you feel the pain
you notice the disappointment you never
want to suppress that that would build
up the toxic emotions within you so feel
the just disappointment if it's you know
you forgot your keys somewhere
you lost your wallet
you missed the train
you missed a meeting you lost a sale
or maybe it's something heavier
you just got your heart broken
you just lost your job
uh you just got some negative news from
your doctor it's your annual
checkup
i mean that's one of the things that
happens in life we all face very hard
times
when those things happen feel the
emotion do not suppress it because the
quickest way out of the
painful or sad emotions is straight in
but here's the real key ask yourself
what's the opportunity here
how can i use
this small or a large
negative event to grow
how can i use this situation
to give me more wisdom to give me more
acumen
to make me more experienced how can i
use this situation to strengthen me and
fortify me how can i use this situation
to become more authentic and more real
because it's the difficult things in
life that crack open our social mask and
allow us to be more real and more
authentic how can i use this situation
to build my relatability so i'm more
relatable to human beings and ultimately
how can i use this situation as fuel to
make my life even better so on our
little planet we're actually
it's a core philosophy of mine we're
brothers and sisters on a little planet
that person
that homeless person was someone's
dreams at a time
the
person in the restaurant or the hotel
who it's very easy if we're numbed out
and not awake i'm not someone's father
or mother
and
when i look at most people on the planet
it's no judgment i just
i see people who are they're in scarcity
versus generosity i see so many people
saying you know when i was a kid i had
all this creativity i don't know where
it happened you see it every day you
know you have all these people i want to
build a business oh i i oh i guess i ca
it's psychology of can't versus
mentality of possibility i see people
in pain i see people playing victim i
mean when you agree most people on the
planet at some foreign form or another
whether it's with their creativity or
their prosperity or their personal lives
they're they're stuck in victimhood i
would say pleasing
comes from fear
and a lack of
standing in your true power
there's a distinction i make in the 5
a.m club between fake power
big office for example lots of money
jets
titles that's fake power
true power is
mother teresa
mahatma gandhi he died with under 10
possessions that's true power he he did
not get his power from who he was in the
world and by pleasing people
he got his power by intimacy with his
highest nature that's true power so
what's the difference between pleasing
and service pleasing comes from
scarcity and fear
self-loathing and insecurity
if they don't like me
then i'm not enough
well you know any great genius any the
great women and men of the world
stood alone even if they were an army of
one galileo coco chanel catherine graham
shakespeare
john michelle basquiat
if you look at the great producers of
the planet they were ridiculed before
they were revered you can change the
world or you can be liked by everyone
you don't get to do both
so service comes from
here's my vision
maybe it's the internet maybe it's apple
maybe it's you know writing a book or a
movie here's my vision
and even if the world laughs at me
i am so strong
in my vision to serve to disrupt the
field to bring on value and to live my
truth that even if they shoot me and
take a bullet
i will continue at all costs
that is a titan that's a legend
but a lot of us have not done the inner
excavation and that's why i go back to
the four interior empires that's why the
5am club five to six the victory hour
doing the protocols that i teach in the
book is transformational because the
doorway to success doesn't open outward
if you get it inward and build that core
that warrior
meets poe itself you go out in the world
you're powerful you said that
everybody should have core values what
is what are some of your most deeply
cherished core values
service above self
in other words contribution impact
service
number two
family
i mean
if i could be a tenth of the human being
my two children are i'd be a
i'd be
i'd be amazing
family you know
i've worked very hard but i've
really
worked hard on my family too even trying
to be a great son you know great brother
all those things because we all know to
get to the last day of your last
of your life and say i made a lot of
money and i got a lot of likes and i
sold a lot of books and i impact a lot
of people
and your own family never got to know
you that's heartbreak
third value i'm an asset the french word
lover of beauty
you know that's why you know that's why
i love los angeles like we were coming
over here and it's like
there's flowers you know it's whatever
time of the year is the flowers
everywhere you know
um so i love beauty and art and food and
people and sunsets and that's why i love
rome so much now that fourth value would
be um vitality
you know i really do believe that
the the one of the keys to legendary is
longevity i mean i want to live till 177
i want to you know
right i mean i'm biohacking and i'm
resting and i'm doing the two massage
protocol and everything possible
so i can be rocking my craft and serving
as many people as possible when i'm into
you know i mean one of the things i'd
say is you never want to let an old
person anywhere near the inside of your
body right because and we could get into
epigenetics and the fact that we have a
chronological age and a biological age
but vitality is important and i think
the final core value is lifestyle
you know we can serve the world and
that's very important i know to both of
us
but i want it's life is ultimately a
really short ride
and so i want to really be around only
people
i mean i am focused i only want people
in my orbit that bring me joy or fuel my
joy i only want to do the pursuits in my
business and career and life that bring
me joy and i only go to places where i
feel joy we were born into brilliance
the saints and mystics and philosophers
have talked about it you know
as we go out in the world
we take on the beliefs and the emotional
patterns
of those who influence us
you know and then what happens is we
actually
forget who we truly are
one thing that i think is very important
is also build intimacy with mortality
because you know sometimes
people probably ask you this to ask me
this what do you want to be remembered
for well i i'm pretty clear i'll be dust
hopefully i'll get to live a long life
but i'll be dust and no one will
remember me aside from my family
you know and
so why make it about ego and as we
connect with our mortality we realize
what life is really about and that's a
great thing to do from five to six
o'clock in the morning like in that
second pocket of the 20 20 20 formula
right in your journal on the last hour
for my last day what do i want said
about me and have the discipline to
architect your life so each day is a
mountain climb towards that mount
everest i know this sounds simple but
it's so powerful
so many people say yes when this happens
i will do this
when i have more time i'll write the
book
when i make more money i'll invest in my
growth
when i get the promotion i'll take the
travel
no one knows what tomorrow brings no one
knows what tomorrow brings no one knows
what tomorrow brings keep on asking
yourself if i don't do this now
how will i feel later
so don't wait
i'm not saying be foolish
you want to definitely not make ill
considered choices
and at the same time do not wait i think
there's just an opportunity for people
when they bring their full presence and
their heart to their work you will be
seen now given the landscape as
extraordinary
in the 5am club i call it a gca a
gargantuan competitive advantage yeah it
has never been it has never been so
uncrowded at world class because so few
people are doing the fundamentals of
world class
so few people literally sit down in in
blocks of time create what i call a
tight bubble of total focus and do real
work versus fake work tranquility is the
new luxury
so whether you're a homemaker a
professional athlete an entrepreneur a
pizza builder
maybe that's not the term of art
but you do your best work
we have our greatest impact and we are
most true to our best selves when we're
tranquil
peaceful and serene and that's another
value of joining the 5 a.m club because
those hours before the sun rises are the
most peaceful magical quiet period of
the day and if we can anchor in who we
truly want to be before we go out into a
messy world well we're going to
fundamentally behave differently i think
marie life's greatest heartbreak is
being untrue to yourself
and
i come from very humble beginnings i
have a great family and yet the people
around me said if you become a lawyer
like i basically had a choice become an
engineer a doctor or a lawyer
and so i followed through on that and i
went to law school and i
became a really successful litigation
lawyer
and i had you know a nice place to live
and had a nice car and i was making
great money and people said i'm on
you're on your way to being a judge
and yet i would wake up every morning
and i would look at myself in the
bathroom mirror and i didn't like or
even know the person who was looking
back at me and that i love that word
angst you know that angst just got to a
point where i said i had to make some
changes
and so i started listening to that
silent whisper of my heart you know
there's there's something i believe in
which is instinct is much more powerful
and wiser than intellect and i think
when all of us trust our intel our
instinct in a world that says intellect
and logic is everything we we start to
enter what mr reilly in the 5am club
calls the magic and that's sort of what
happened to me i find your destiny
doesn't knock it whispers
and so it wasn't
this epiphany you know it was just
um
i think when you start to trust your
instinct and trust yourself versus the
world and you sort of block out the
opinions of other people
the pace of synchronicity starts to open
up and these doors that you're supposed
to walk through start to present
themselves to you i've gone through
situations where
yeah people have tried to take me down
you're absolutely right i've had 10
years of my personal journals
where i pour my heart my confusion my
pain my hopes my dream i've had those um
i'll just simply say taken wow which
taught me detachment
wow louis imagine do you journal um a
little bit here and there yes a little
bit okay journaling is like incredible
powerful yeah for self-excavation for
creativity productivity we can get into
epigenetics
you know if you want to rewire your
psychology as well as your heart
journaling is powerful but i've had
those taken away from you
just taken away from 10 years of
journals oh 10 years of journals oh my
god all your private thoughts all my
private messages
exactly so that's just one thing that
i've gone through
um so what was the lesson there learning
detachment and letting go not caring
about the opinions of others or yeah
i've there's been another time of my
life and i don't think i've ever shared
this publicly but
where there was
a situation where i could have lost
everything that i've spent 22 years
in this field of leadership and personal
personal mastery building
which again
taught me
what real wealth and success is all
about i mean there's a line in the 5 a.m
club which is your piece of nothing is
worth the price of your peace of mind
and we live in a world where a lot of
people this is right out of the book an
addiction to distraction is the death of
creative production there are a lot of
cyber zombies on the planet there are a
lot of people on the planet right now
giving the best hours of their finest
days to the white screen of
attractions
and i i really think that
betraying your genius every single
person on the planet has primal genius
within them that's scientifically proven
we can talk about it i go into it in the
book
but playing with your phone versus
pursuing your monuments of mastery is
betraying not only yourself i think it's
betraying the world and so i really
believe and i've experienced it for two
decades with my clients getting up at 5
a.m and running this calibrated 20 20 20
formula that much of the book is about
will take any human being to a new level
of creativity productivity prosperity
and service to humanity
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there